welcome back to New rockstars I'm
Whitney van leningham and my brain hole
is still blown from the across the
spider verse trailer I'm sure I'm not
the only one here wondering why all
these Spider-Man are attacking Miles
Morales what exactly does he do to
Warrant him getting dogpiled on by
dozens of multiversal spider totems I
have a theory that we may find ourselves
in the midst of a spidey on Spidey Civil
War or as John Watts would call it
Spider-Man home War when we last Saw
miles at the end of into the
spider-verse it was revealed that Gwen
found a way to reliably travel the
Multiverse and the teaser we saw last
December seemingly picks up here with
Gwen stopping by to check in on her pal
and do some superheroics the hexagonal
portal Tech she's using as well as the
bracelet she Sports look to all be
inventions by Miguel O'Hara AKA
Spider-Man 2099 of earth928 we saw the
beginnings of this in the post-credits
scene of into the spider-verse where
Miguel and his AI Lyla invent autonomous
multiversal travel and he began to
recruit a team of web warriors according
to the official Sony synopsis this movie
follows Brooklyn's full-time friendly
neighborhood Spider-Man as he's
catapulted across the Multiverse
encountering a team of spider people
charged with protecting its very
existence these are essentially the web
warriors or spider force from the comics
who defend the web of life and Destiny
that connects the Multiverse very
clearly Miguel is leading this operation
and Glenn is part of his Spidey Squad
according to the post-trailer interview
with producer and co-writers Phil Lord
and Chris Miller and actor Haley
Steinfeld When Stacy is invited into the
spider club and Miles pointedly isn't
and it's low-key because he isn't cool
enough to hang for a specific reason
that Stacy isn't telling him Lord said
to Steinfeld quote basically you got
invited into Oscar Isaacs AKA Miguel's
cool spider Force you get invited into
the spider society and Miles doesn't and
you sort of can't tell him why the fact
that Gwen is keeping a secret from miles
is a very interesting mystery box that
will Circle back to trying to crack open
for now let's examine the spider Society
I think that we're going to see Miguel
enforce the rules of his
interdimensional superhighway guarding
the Multiverse from other Travelers with
nefarious intentions after all with
great power comes great responsibility
judging by how the first movie
established that multiversal travel can
come with dangerous hiccups from
incursions to the complete cellular
Decay that's clearly a responsibility
that weighs heavy on Miguel but I think
it's how he carries out that
responsibility that ultimately leads to
his conflict with Miles and that Miller
Lord Steinfeld interview Miller notes
that the first movie was about the idea
that anyone can wear the mask while this
movie is about how do you wear the mask
so not only do I immediately know that
this film will do a multiversal Uncle
Ben speech cutaway gag but we know that
this film will explore methods and
degrees of balancing power with
responsibility how miles handles cram
fighting and prevention versus how
Miguel handles crime fighting and
prevention this is where the villain of
the movie suspiciously missing from the
trailer The Spot comes in the rest of
the official synopsis basically tells us
that the way miles approaches the spot
versus how Miguel approaches the spot is
the core conflict of the movie it states
when the heroes Clash on how to handle a
new threat miles finds himself pitted
against the other spiders and must
redefine what it means to be a hero so
he can save the people he loves most so
how can the spot factor into all of this
in the comics Dr Jonathan on was a
scientist hired by Kingpin to recreate
the cloak's teleportation Powers his
research sent him to a dimension of half
Darkness Half-Life surrounded by portals
that he called spot world after finding
his way back to his original Dimension
he discovered that the portals had stuck
to his skin allowing him to space War
although the comics paint the spot as a
joke cross the spider-verse producer
Kent Powers warns us that when you
really look at his powers there's
incredible potential and he's right
mortal travel is no joke I'm wielding a
power like that definitely comes with
great great great great great
responsibility you don't F around with
the Multiverse just ask Tom Holland's
Peter Parker oh wait you can't because
he messed up the Multiverse so bad that
everyone forgot he existed there is not
a single person on the planet who hasn't
seen anything Star Wars and not wanted a
lightsaber that's a scientific fact now
you can bring the science fiction weapon
of your dreams into the reality of your
life with Ona saber Ona saber makes
super high quality replicas of
lightsabers like this one
[Applause]
so good
this is the SN pixel model of the Doom
saber and it rules fun fact we almost
missed our deadline for shooting a video
today because we were running around the
office pretending to be Jedi this thing
is awesome the hilt is made from metal
aluminum alloy so it has a good heft to
it and the blade is polycarbonate so you
don't have to worry about it shattering
if you you know the whack a co-worker
with it the saber also has a txq RGB
soundboard that lets you make the same
sounds you'd hear in any Star Wars show
or movie like Blaster blocks lockups and
blade tip drags
you can also choose from nine different
blade colors so you can change your
safer to suit your strategically
shifting alliances on a saber is
currently offering free shipping on all
orders made during December and if you
use code rockstars at checkout you can
save an additional 20 off making this
the perfect gift for all the Jedi and
Sith on your list just click the link in
the description below or go to
onasaber.com to find your saber today so
here we have a character with the power
to jump dimensions and who can do so
without Miguel's Tech consent or safety
precautions whether the spot knows it or
not that makes him a multiversal threat
Miguel's job is to eliminate threats and
how does Miguel eliminate threats Awards
excessive force come to mind not only do
we see him ragdolling miles across
Dimensions but the Comic version of
Miguel is pretty brutal and the crew of
across the spider verse reportedly
nicknamed him property damage Spider-Man
because everything gets destroyed in
this dude's wake miles on the other hand
will likely take a more sympathetic
approach to the spot according to
producer Kent Powers the spot in miles
are connected in surprising ways which
leads me to believe that the spot
they're fighting over will be from the
same universe as miles like his comic
counterpart the spot was likely a
scientist who was working on fisk's
forays into dimensional travel he may
have even been an unseen casualty when
Fisk rebooted his particle collider
possibly trapped between Dimensions when
miles shut it down another villain
inadvertently created by a Spider-Man
from an article in variety back in June
2022 we learned that the spot's
character design will evolve as the
character does it said quote as the
filmmakers explained the villain will
feature a character design meant to call
to mind an unfinished sketch featuring
Blue construction lines that evoke a
comic book artist rough drawing before
the work goes on to an anchor the design
itself will evolve over the course of
the film as the character changes and
grows taking on a more fearsome shape as
he learns to better apply his own powers
this to me sounds like Dr Ahn is almost
being slowly regenerated back into
reality like Dr Manhattan when he first
got his powers if spot's Powers were the
result of an accident like they were in
the comics miles would understand where
he was coming from especially if he
doesn't know exactly how to control his
powers miles didn't know how to control
his either but I think the interpersonal
spider drama goes deeper than just
Miguel trying to kill the Spot while
miles tries to help him control his
powers like obviously I gotta bring up
the Dead kid hint right in the trailer
we see Miguel gazing at an old photo of
him and his daughter Gabriella eating
ice cream which combined with the fact
that all Spider-Man experience a tragic
loss hints that she's most likely
deceased it wouldn't be all that
surprising to find out that the spot is
somehow partially responsible for
Gabriella's death but what if Miguel's
spot isn't miles's spot as far as we
know only two Dimensions have
successfully invented the means to jump
into the Multiverse to me this says that
we can expect to see the spot slowly
come into his powers in the same way
that Miles had to learn to control his
so here's where one part of my Theory
comes in what if the spot's Powers
somehow directly or indirectly caused
the death of Miguel's daughter if he ran
into Miguel and Gabriella while he was
still trying to get the gist of his
powers he could have made a mistake that
ultimately cost the little girl her life
the person who killed Gabriella may not
have been the spot we're gonna see
voiced by Jason Schwartzman it could
have been as long ago very from Nuevo
York our version of the spot could have
gotten his powers in kingpin's busted
portal explosion and was thrust into
spot world just like his comic
counterpart perhaps the spider vs
version of the spot Dimension is even
connected to the Web of Life and Destiny
if this hypothetical situation is true
he would have gained the ability to
instantly do what took Miguel years to
invent when he emerged this could
explain why Miguel is so hell-bent on
protecting the Multiverse and
controlling interdimensional travel as
much as possible if the person he loved
most was killed by careless space
warping I could see him making it his
life's mission to prevent something like
that ever happening again and that's
where part two of this Theory comes in
if miles learns that Miguel wants to
kill or punish the spot for his
inability to control his extreme Powers
he could take the spot side after all he
just spent the entirety of into the
spider-verse struggling to master his
own powers and if miles is struggling to
fit into the pool crowd at Spidey
Central he could turn a sympathetic eye
to a fellow Outcast if this is the case
and Miles protests against Miguel's
harsh roles in favor of a more
compassionate treatment of the spot we
could very well have a Spider-Man Civil
War on our hands in the same way that
Tony and cap fought over what to do
about the sokovia Accords we might see
miles and Miguel go head to head each
believing that their side is right if
Miguel sees taking spot out as a part of
his duty to protect the Multiverse miles
May argue to give this guy a chance like
Iron Man and Steve Rogers both Miguel
and miles would have valid reasons for
their beliefs but wouldn't be able to
compromise and it's possible that this
is when things get ugly for Miles with
Miguel blindly determined to keep the
spider-verse from harm this could be
when he calls for the rest of the
spideys to turn against the Party
Crasher we do know that Gwen eventually
calls Miguel out saying we are supposed
to be the good guys so my guess is that
she eventually sees that his methods
aren't as heroic as she and the others
thought that they were miles won't be
alone in this fight for long and after
clashing with Miguel on how to handle
the spot they may need to work together
to stop this portal jumper from growing
strong enough to break the Multiverse
ultimately I believe that the theme of
this movie is going to be about how each
Spider-Man chooses to wear the mask are
Miguel's more aggressive tactics against
the spot's presence the right way to
handle things or is miles is
non-judgmental more understanding
approach better well miles is naivete
and past experiences blind him towards
the spot's capacity for harm and will
Miguel find humanity in his Nemesis
we're gonna have to wait till 2023 to
find out but in the meantime I want to
know you guys think in the comments
follow me on Instagram and Twitter at
whitneypuppy follow new rockstars
subscribe to new rockstars for more
analysis of everything you love and
thanks for watching bye
thank you
foreign
[Music]